We're now going to look at the confusion matrix.
It is important to know that selecting a model is dependent on
the problem being considered and the application of the model.
Often for
practical problems, we're interested in measures other than just accuracy.
Let us consider a kind of contrived example.
We have many bottles of wine, where some are poisoned.
In this case,
it is important that we always catch the bottles of wine that are poisoned.
So labeling a good bottle of wine as poisoned, which is a false negative,
implies some wasted wine.
However, labeling a poisoned bottle as good,
which is a false negative, can imply a far dangerous mistake.
So, in this case, we can sacrifice accuracy for some other measure where we give
a lot more value at minimizing the false negatives versus the false positives.
Here is a quick quiz.
Give an example of a classification problem where the cost of
a false positive outweighs the cost of a false negative.
When you have thought of the example, click on the box here.